Зрубати дерево за 10 секунд - як це можливо
Чому у ФРН немає нелегальної вирубки
Хто є головним ворогом німецьких лісів
Друзі, всім привіт! Після виходу серій про розплідники дерев та про догляд за деревами у парках ФРН
у коментарях ви просили показати, як функціонує лісове господарство.
Виконую ваше побажання! Це ліс Коттенфорст поблизу Бонна.
Ходімо одразу до головного лісника і розпитаємо, як тут все у нього організовано.
В офіс посеред лісу мене запрошує Штефан Шютте - керівник регіонального управління лісів.
Одразу на вході - сучасне мистецтво. Неймовірна куля з дерева -
всі її деталі виготовлені бензопилою.
Пан Шютте починає своє пояснення зі структури власності лісів у ФРН
на прикладі його регіонального управління. Загалом відповідальність за ліси
у федеральній землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія поділена між 16 такими управліннями.
У Німеччині близько 45-48 відсотків лісів -
у приватній власності. Ці кольорові ділянки  - державний ліс.
Маємо приблизно третину лісів, які належать федеральним землям.
Так званий "бундесвальд" -  це тренувальні полігони Бундесверу - 2,5 відсотка
лісів Німеччини.Лісове управління відповідальне за весь ліс.
Цікаво, що на східних територіях, де була НДР, досі триває
процес повернення приватних лісів, які були націоналізовані.
Нащадки власників мають право їх викупити за ціною, яка значно нижча за ринкову.
Я вже хочу їхати до лісу, однак пан Шютте не поспішає.
Вияляється, третину свого робочого часу він, як не дивно,
проводить за паперами і комп‘ютером.
Жовтий колір - це дуб, коричневий - бук,
сірий - сосна, синій - ялина.
Більш насиченим кольором позначені старіші дерева -
темно-жовтий наприклад - це старі дуби,
менш насичений світло-жовтий - це дуб молодого та середнього віку.
А ось тут, наприклад, позначена ділянка 1056,
за цим номером у мене в комп'ютері є додаток, де записано, скільки саме на цій ділянці дерев,
якого типу вони і віку, як розростаються і що ми з кожним деревом плануємо робити у наступні 10 років.
За кожним лісником закріплена ділянка у 1500 гектарів.
У підпорядкуванні Штефана Шютте - 26 лісників.
Вони теж на автівках, зустрічаємо їх по дорозі.
Одразу в очі кидається те, що дороги в Коттенфорсті
прокладені як під лінійку.
Як бачите, шлях пролягає дуже прямо, це одна зі старих просік для полювання.
Адже Коттенфорст раніше був мисливським угіддям кельнського курфюрста.
Тут в центрі селища поблизу був його замок, а по старих просіках мисливці
скакали у ліс,щоб добре пополювати.
Дощі не вщухали вжетри дні, тож перевзуваємося у трекінгові чоботи і вперед,
на огляд ділянки номер 1056. Тут ростуть переважно дуби.
Вік цього лісу 120 років.
Ми називаємо їх деревами майбутнього і позначаємо білою крапкою.
У цього дерева гарний стовбур, крона ще повинна розвинутися.
Дереву потрібен простір, щоб рости.  Саме тому раз на 5-10 років
ми прибираємо дерева навколо, які на заваді росту.
Діаметр цього дуба 45 сантиметрів, наша мета - діаметр щонайменше 60-80 сантиметрів.
Для цього дубові треба рости ще 80 років.
А через 80 років він дозріє для вирубки, як відгодована свиня.
Тоді ми його зрубаємо і продамо, а на цій ділянці знову буде прямий доступ сонця,
на вивільненому місці засіються жолуді з сусідніх дубів і виникне новий ліс.
У Німеччині переходять до наближеного до природнього лісівництва,
коли деревину на продаж рубають вибірково у міру старішання
і намагаються уникати суцільних рубок. Однак через зміни клімату і аномально
спекотні останні літа у ФРН загинули понад триста тисяч гектарів ялинового лісу.
Ось фото крупним планом головного винуватця трагедії - знайомтесь, жук-короїд.
Через нього знову повернулися до практики тотальних рубок -
це єдиний метод боротьби, розпилювання хімікатів на ліс з повітря у ФРН заборонене.
Відірвавши шматок кори, можна побачити: ось тут самка відклала яйця.
З яєць вилуплюються личинки жука, які потім прогризають горизонтальні проходи в корі
ліворуч і праворуч, у такий спосіб руйнуючи так би мовити судини дерева.
У підсумку маємо ось таку цілковито знищену структуру кори.
Дерево більше не здатне постачати воду знизу до крони і зрештою помирає.
Таке відбувається лише тому, що дерево ослаблене через роки посухи.
Короїд пошкоджує лише кору, сама деревина залишається неушкодженою і придатною
для промислової обробки. Через короїда на ринку ФРН виникла пропозиція ялини,
що в сотні разів перевищує попит. Основним покупцем німецької ялини зараз є Китай,
де економіка здатна поглинати таку кількість деревини.
Взагалі ялини не притаманні цьому регіону.
Їх висаджували після Другої світової, бо в сусідньому вугільному Рурському регіоні
ялини потрібні були для укріплення забоїв у підземних шахтах.
Тепер на вивільнених територіях вирощуватимуть лише змішаний з шести різновидів дерев
листяний ліс. А яка ж ситуація з нелегальною вирубкою?
Ми спостерігаємо, що у світі зараз ведеться багато нелегальної вирубки.
У Німеччині, слава Богу, такої проблеми немає. Кожен лісник відповідальний за ділянку
у тисячу п'ятсот гектарів лісу.
Він добре знає ділянку, постійно об'їжджає її і контролює. Це важливо.
Лісник мусить бути присутній у лісі, жити тут. Не діло, коли лісник живе
у найближчому великому місті, за 20 кілометрів від лісу
і навідується лише раз на тиждень.
Постійна присутність лісника на ділянці - це передумова,
щоб у лісі все було під контролем.
Штефан Шютте вимагає від своїх 26 лісників, аби ті знали усі дерева
на своїх ділянках і обходили її практично щодня. Лісник з роками вже знає в обличчя
всіх бігунів, вершників та велосипедистів, які мешкають неподалік. Чужих у лісі одразу видно.
Я не здавався і запитав, а чи можливо вкрасти вже спиляні колоди.
Кожна колода має номер - ця з номером триста.
Також лісоруби написали що колода завдовжки сім метрів і завтовшки 34 сантиметри.
Ці дані заносяться в комп’ютер. Далі трактор витягує колоду ось туди до дороги,
де вже її може приїхати вибрати покупець. На цій ділянці вирубано близько 400 дерев,
тобто у нас є інвентарний список колод. Список отримує лісопилка,
яка обробляє нашу деревину і знає, що мають надійти 395 стовбурів
загальним обсягом 250 кубічних метрів якісної деревини дуба.
А далі домовляємось про ціну.
Звичайно ж і така інвентаризація не завада злому умислу,
однак, вивчаючи тему, я помітив, що німці ще у 19 столітті усвідомили,
як нещадно вирубували ліси у середньовіччі і що необхідно висаджувати нові
і розсудливо ставитися до цього ресурсу. Про це свідчать охайні карти лісництва
19 століття, де вже рахували дерева і планували вирубку.
Їду подивитися, а як же ж зараз легально рубають дерева.
У цьому казковому будинку лісника живе і працює підлеглий пана Шютте -
Єнс Мерцбах. Їдемо з ним на інспекцію ділянки.
Аби водії машин знали, куди у лісі можна заїжджати
на вирубку, я маркую дерева ось такими білими лініями.
Сподівався побачити бригаду лісорубів які працюють бензопилами, однак побачив це.
Просто неймовірна техніка - одна людина робить роботу цілої бригади.
Це "гарвестер" - комбайн для автоматизованої рубки лісу.
Ви лише подивіться на цю машину - її вартість півмільйона євро.
Це гарвестерна голівка - головний робочий агрегат,
який має в собі кілька механізмів: пилу для валки дерева, пристрій для утримання
і протягування стовбура та пристрій обрізки гілок і сучків.
Ну що ж, подивимось, як працює ця диво-машина.
Сьогодні водій - це пан Собель з Польщі, попрацюємо з ним разом.
Водій - це все ж не зовсім вірно, бо коли я заліз в кабіну, то не побачив жодного керма.
Швидше Петер Собель - оператор комбайну. Обидві руки лежать на джойстиках у формі кулі.
То є важка робота? Чи подобається вам працювати?
- То єсть хороша!
Гарвестер за десять секунд валить дерево. Ще за 25 знімає всі гілки
і розрізає його на три колоди. Більше часу за сам процес рубки займає під'їзд до дерева
і обрання безпечної і зручної дистанції. При цьому це ще й гора.
Ми стоїмо під нахилом 20 градусів.
- За робочу зміну я спилюю до 400 дерев.
Актуальна моя продуктивність - ось на моніторі -
19 дерев на годину, зазвичай показник 24 дерева на годину.
Ось така продуктивність праці.
Серед обов'язків лісника - ще й робота з громадськістю.
Багато людей, гуляючи лісом, питають, навіщо ви з такою швидкістю вирубаєте ліс -
завдання лісника пояснити. Для цього ставлять інформаційні таблички.
Аби привернути увагу до змін клімату і до того, як змінюється внаслідок цього ліс,
проводять лекції для дорослих і вистави для дітей. І в лісі не обійшлося без сучасного митецтва.
Християнський хрест, зірка Давида як символ юдаїзму та ісламський півмісяць.
Всі три культури повинні об'єднатися. Адже лише спільно усвідомивши
кліматичну кризу та зміни, осягнувши їх, можна разом відповідно діяти,
сміливо рухатися у майбутнє. Це намагався сказати митець
цим поєднанням трьох великих світових релігій.
А далі за залізною скульптурою пожухлий ліс і великими літерами
напис: "Зміна часу". Така масштабна інсталяція вражає
і дає змогу осягнути глобальність виклику, який постав перед людством.
Пишіть, що ще вам цікаво дізнатися про Німеччину! Побачимось!